Welcome back to recitation.
What I'd like us to do
in these two problems
is to understand how to compute
the flux in three dimensions--
the flux of a vector in three
dimensions-- across a surface,
without maybe doing a
lot of calculations.
So we're going to see
if we can figure out
how to do these problems without
doing a lot of computation.
So the first one is to find
the flux of the vector k
through the infinite
cylinder x squared
plus y squared equals 1.
So notice this doesn't depend on
z, but in fact, at every height
it is a unit circle.
So it's an infinite cylinder.
And then the second problem
I'd like you to think about
and to try is to find
the flux of the vector j
through one square that has
side length 1 in the xz-plane.
So you pick any square, in
the xz-plane, of side length 1
and find the flux of
j through that square.
And so I think that
that's enough information.
So why don't you try
both of those problems,
pause the video,
and then when you're
ready to see my explanation
of how they work,
bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
Again, what we're
trying to do is
to understand the flux of a
vector field across a surface.
And we're hoping to
do it with the least
amount of calculation possible,
for these particular problems.
So obviously it's
going to be helpful
if you can draw a picture,
to draw a picture.
So I'm going to draw
the surface that
is the infinite cylinder
first and then I'm
going to look at
the vector field k.
So let me draw my picture first.
If these are my
coordinate axes, I
get-- I think you have
something usually like this.
This is x, this is
y, and this is z.
This is how you do
them in your class.
And so it's not going
to be a great picture
but I'm going to try and make
it look like a cylinder up
here coming down.
So this is in fact going
to be infinitely long,
going down forever, but I'll
stop at somewhere down here.
And then so every slice in the
z, at a fixed height for z,
is going to be a circle.
I should think about these are
intersecting the x- and y- axes
at (1, 0) and (0, 1).
So there's actually a sort of
unit circle down here as well.
Now that's the surface.
Now what does the
vector field look like?
Well, in general what does
the vector field look like?
k is just a constant
vector field
that points in this direction.
This is k.
So k at every point
on the surface
is just the vector
that's pointing straight
up in this direction.
And the normal to the surface,
if you think about it,
the normal to the surface
is independent of z.
It doesn't depend on z at all.
It is always going
to be a vector that
is in the x-y direction only.
It's going to be--
essentially at every point,
it's going to be sitting in
the plane z equals a constant.
Because if you think
about what you have,
you have a unit circle
at every height.
And it doesn't vary
in the z-direction
at all, the bending
of that unit circle.
So in fact the normal is always
going to point straight out
from the unit circle.
There's going to
be no z-component.
Or I should say the
z-component's 0.
Maybe that's the
best way to say it.
So that means that the normal
dotted with k is going to be 0.
And so the answer to the first
question is the flux of k
through the infinite
cylinder is actually 0.
So the answer to part a is 0.
Been getting a lot of
zeroes in my video so far.
The next one is to find
the flux of the vector j
through one square
in the xz-plane
where the squares
have side length 1.
So I can draw any square I want.
That seems to imply
that maybe it'll
be the same answer everywhere.
So let's see what we get.
Let me draw a
picture for part b.
Label this first maybe.
Let me label my axes.
And I'm going to draw
the simplest one I can.
That does not look like a square
but I'm not great at this.
There we go.
So this is my surface
sitting in the x-z plane.
This side length is 1 and
this side length is 1.
So what is the normal
to that surface?
Well, we have two choices
and so we will actually have
a possibility of two answers.
So let me point out that
the normal to the surface--
well, what direction
does it point in?
Because this plane
is in the xz-plane,
the normal to the surface
is either j or it's minus j.
And so if I'm
integrating j dotted
with the normal over
the surface-- I'll just
call this surface capital R--
if I'm integrating over R j
dotted with the
normal dS, j dotted
with the normal is going
to be either 1 or minus 1.
And hopefully that
makes sense because j--
let me draw this-- j is pointing
exactly in the y-direction.
And the normal is
either in this direction
or in the opposite direction.
Up to how I choose to
orient the surface.
And so j dotted with n is
either plus or minus 1,
and so I just get the area of
R with a plus or minus-- ooh,
that doesn't look
like a plus or minus--
with a plus or minus in front.
Depending on whether
j dotted with n is 1
or whether j dotted
with n is minus 1.
So the solution for
this computation
is just the area of R or
minus the area of R. Well,
what's the area of the region?
The area, it's a square of side
length 1, so it has area 1.
So the final answer is
just plus or minus 1.
So again, let me remind you
what we're trying to do.
We're trying to
determine these fluxes
of vector fields across
surfaces without doing
a lot of calculation.
And in the first case
we had a vector field
that pointed in the
z-direction only,
and the normal was only
in the x and y direction.
And so the flux was
0, even though it
was a vector field on
an infinite cylinder,
the flux was still 0.
And in the other case,
I had actually here, I
had a surface that was
exactly in the xz-plane.
And so its normal was exactly
either in the same direction
as j or 180 degrees
around from j.
So j dotted with the normal
was either plus or minus 1.
And so I only had to know
the area of the region.
Which is why it didn't matter
where I moved this unit square.
I didn't tell you where
the unit square had to sit,
so that's where you can
see why it didn't matter.
Because it's just the area.
OK, I think that's
where I'll stop.